THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITOL. I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 113. SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. BUT SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY MEMBERS JUST YET, WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN AS A SUB
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE DO HAVE
FIVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
TWO THAT ARE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
ON PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNELLY ON
AB 1864. HE'S HERE TO PRESENT
PLEASE, PLEASE COME ON UP AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK AND INPUT ON THIS
BILL. CHILDREN ATTENDING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND DAYCARES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE INTENDED TO BE
PROTECTED BY A REGULATION THAT
RESTRICTS THE MOST DRIFT PRONE
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS. DURING THE SCHOOL
DAY, FROM 6 A.M. TO 6 P.M,
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY. IN
PRACTICE, THIS REGULATION IS
OFTEN UNENFORCEABLE, WHILE
NOTICES OF INTENT, AS WE'LL CALL
THEM NOISE, MUST BE SUBMITTED TO
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS BEFORE USING
PESTICIDES CLASSIFIED AS
RESTRICTED MATERIALS AND MUST BE
AND MUST INCLUDE THE METHOD OF
APPLICATION. OFTEN THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED ISN'T
SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE METHOD
TRIGGERS APPLICATIONS OR
REGULATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE, IF THE
APPLICATION METHOD LISTED ON THE
NÓI IS GROUND, IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER THAT MEANS A GROUND RIG
SPRAYER WHICH HAS A DISTANCE
RESTRICTION OR A HAND PUMP
SPRAYER WHICH DOES NOT. FURTHER,
THE EXACT LOCATION OF
APPLICATIONS CANNOT BE VERIFIED
UNDER CURRENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND EXACT START AND
END TIMES ARE OFTEN INACCURATELY
REPORTED. AB 1864 SEEKS TO MAKE
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS BY
REQUIRING ANNUAL PERMITS TO
INCLUDE METHOD OF APPLICATION
AND SPECIFIC SITE IDENTIFICATION
, AND FOR USE REPORTS TO INCLUDE
METHOD AND TIMING OF APPLICATION
TO PROVIDE CORROBORATION THAT
LAWS ARE ADHERED TO. THIS BILL
ALSO ENSURES EQUITY BY EXTENDING
THE SAME PROTECTIONS TO
CHILDREN, TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF IN PRIVATE SCHOOLS. THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND DAYCARES ARE
ALREADY AFFORDED. I'M COMMITTED
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE GIS
LAYER OF THIS BILL, AND
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK THEY
HAVE PROVIDED. SO WITH THAT,
I'LL NOW PASS IT OFF TO MY TWO
WITNESSES, JANE SELIN,
CO-DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM. WELCOME, JANE
AND VICTOR TORRES, REPRESENTING
FUTURE LEADERS OF CHANGE. THANKS
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JANE THELEN. I'M
CO-DIRECTOR OF THE STATEWIDE
COALITION CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM, I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP, FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL. AB 1864.
IT'S A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED FROM
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDE EXPOSURE
AT SCHOOL. THIS BILL IS NEEDED
BECAUSE IN THE SIX YEARS SINCE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION OR DPR
IMPLEMENTED RESTRICTIONS ON
CERTAIN PESTICIDE APPLICATION
METHODS NEXT TO SCHOOLS DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY, GROUND TRUTHING
BY OUR COALITION HAS REVEALED
SOME SERIOUS ISSUES WITH
ENFORCEABILITY, AND THOSE ISSUES
CAN BE ADDRESSED BY SIMPLE
REPORTING CHANGES. SO WE THANK
THE LEGISLATURE FOR STEPPING IN
TO HELP STRENGTHEN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PROTECTION. AND WE
TRULY APPRECIATE THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT BY THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY OF THE NEED
FOR SOME OF THESE MEASURES. THIS
BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE EXISTING
PROTECTIONS TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA, WHICH WERE
PREVIOUSLY NOT INCLUDED IN THE
REGULATION. WITHOUT THESE
PROTECTIONS, THERE'S NOTHING TO
STOP AERIAL APPLICATIONS RIGHT
UP TO THE SCHOOL BOUNDARY.
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY AT PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. PESTICIDE EXPOSURE AT
SCHOOL IS A SERIOUS AND
UNDERREPORTED ISSUE, AS YOU WILL
HEAR FROM CO-SPONSOR VICTOR
TORRES, EVEN AN ACUTE ILLNESS AT
SCHOOL THAT WAS REPORTED AND
RESULTED IN A HOSPITAL VISIT WAS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE STATE
PESTICIDE ILLNESS DATABASE. WE
KNOW THAT CHRONIC EXPOSURE IS AN
ISSUE AT SCHOOLS BECAUSE DFW'S
OWN AIR MONITORING NETWORK
CONFIRMS THE PRESENCE OF
MULTIPLE PESTICIDES IN THE AIR
AT EACH OF ITS MONITORING
STATIONS, SEVERAL OF WHICH ARE
LOCATED ON SCHOOL GROUNDS. SO
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB 1864, THE
MOST DRIFT PRONE APPLICATIONS OF
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDES WILL NO
LONGER OCCUR DURING THE SCHOOL
DAY. WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF
ANY SCHOOL, PUBLIC OR PRIVATE,
AND THE STATE AND COUNTY WILL
HAVE THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
TO ENFORCE THIS COMMON SENSE
RULE. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AND I'LL PASS ON MY
TESTIMONY TO MY COLLEAGUE,
VICTOR TORRES. GOOD MORNING.
HELLO, EVERYBODY. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND BEFORE
ANYTHING, I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST
THANK MR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAMON
CONNOLLY FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
AUTHORING THIS BILL. HELLO. MY
NAME IS VICTOR TORRES. I AM 17
YEARS OLD AND A NEW GRADUATE OF
GREENFIELD HIGH SCHOOL. IN MY
HOMETOWN IN THE HEART OF THE
SALINAS VALLEY. I AM A
CO-FOUNDER WITH FUTURE LEADERS
OF CHANGE BASED IN GREENFIELD
AND WATSONVILLE, AND I AM HERE
TODAY TO BRING AWARENESS ABOUT
THE DANGER OF PESTICIDE
APPLICATION NEAR OUR SCHOOLS. I
MYSELF WAS A VICTIM OF PESTICIDE
DRIFT AT THE AGE OF TEN AT MY
LOCAL MIDDLE SCHOOL. NO CHILD
SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH IN A PLACE OF LEARNING.
NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO BE
RUSHED TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM FOR
SOMETHING OUT OF THEIR CONTROL.
WE NEED BETTER PROTECTIONS
AROUND SCHOOLS, BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US
TO KNOW THE EXACT LOCATION OF
PESTICIDE APPLICATION AND HOW
THE PESTICIDES ARE APPLIED. THIS
WOULD IN FACT, GUARANTEE THAT NO
OTHER TEN YEAR OLD HAS TO
EXPERIENCE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HAVING SUCH DANGEROUS CHEMICALS
APPLIED NEAR THEIR SCHOOLS. WHEN
I WAS A VICTIM OF PESTICIDE
DRIFT, THERE WERE EIGHT
DIFFERENT PESTICIDES INVOLVED.
FOUR OF THE EIGHT ARE KNOWN TO
TRIGGER ASTHMA. ANOTHER OF THE
EIGHT WAS HDAC3 OR DCPA. THE US
EPA NOW SAYS ALLOWABLE LEVELS OF
DCPA ARE 1500 TIMES MORE HARMFUL
TO DEVELOPING BRAINS THAN IS
CONSIDERED SAFE. HALF OF ALL
DCPA USE IN CALIFORNIA IS IN MY
COUNTY. MONTEREY COUNTY. THERE
ARE 29 GROWERS WHO PLAN TO APPLY
DCPA WITHIN ONE QUARTER OF A
MILE OF 65 SCHOOLS IN MONTEREY
COUNTY. IN THE CURRENT SCHOOL
YEAR. WE ARE THE FUTURE LEADERS
OF CHANGE IN THE COMMUNITY, AND
I ASK YOU ALL TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO NOT ONLY
LEARN, MEET WITH PEERS, BUT TO
ALSO ENJOY OUR CHILDHOOD IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME UP, STATE
YOUR NAME, POSITION AND
ORGANIZATION. ABBY ALVAREZ, ON
BEHALF OF STOP OAK EXPANSION
COALITION, INDIVISIBLE ALTA
PASADENA, THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS, AND THE BAY
AREA SYSTEM CHANGE, NOT CLIMATE
CHANGE. GOOD MORNING, REBECCA
MARCUS, REPRESENTING THE CENTER
FOR FOOD SAFETY AND CALPIRG IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. Ã. GOOD
MORNING, CHRIS MYERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
DIEGO TORRES. I'M A CO-FOUNDER
OF THE FUTURE LEADERS OF CHANGE,
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. HELLO. MY NAME IS ALEXIA.
ALEXIA RANGEL, CO-FOUNDER OF THE
FUTURE LEADERS OF CHANGE, AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT WITH OUR
BILL, AB 1864 AND ALSO IN BEHALF
OF CAP 805 CENTER ON RACE,
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
POISON FREE MALIBU RECALL
ENERGY, ALBA AND GMO SCIENCE.
ORG THANK. MY NAME IS TORRES. I
SUPPORT 1864 USHA SHARMA ON
BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS CRISTINA
GONZALEZ. ESTOY APOYANDO. THANK
YOU. MI NOMBRE ES IRMA
PLASENCIA. Y ESTOY APOYANDO.
THANK YOU. GRACIAS HELLO, I'M
JALEN JOYCE AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING CCOF AND CFS VALLEY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT. AND
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS
LARA BENITO DE LA COMUNIDAD DE
MADERA, CALIFORNIA. Y ESTOY
APOYANDO AL AL EQUIPO DE TRABAJO
. MUCHAS GRACIAS. MUY BUENOS
DIAS. ROCIO MADRIGAL CON
JUSTICIA. EL CENTRO, CALIFORNIA.
ESTAMOS EN APOYO. ESTAMOS
CANSADOS DE NUESTROS NINOS
THURMOND Y SOLAMENTE LES DICEN
C¯ ES ASMA ADQUIRIDO IN LA
COMUNIDAD B¢O ES DE LOS
PESTICIDES. GRACIAS. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. BILL ALEO,
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DOLORES
HUERTA DOLORES HUERTA FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WENDY
GREENFIELD, SAN JOSE, 37 YEARS
AND WORKING IN EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MJ KUSHNER
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
SUPPORT. HI. MY NAME IS EMMA
FLORES. HI. MY NAME IS EMMA
FLORES. AND I'M SUPPORTED
SUPPORTED. LET'S GO. YOUR NAME
MY NAME IS EMILY FLORES
FRAWLEY'S AND I SUPPORT AND I
SUPPORT. WHAT'S YOUR NAME? MY
NAME IS ELENA AND I SUPPORT AND
I SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
CRISTINA GUTIERREZ WITH CPR. AND
I SUPPORT CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS
ALLIANCE FOR NURSES FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT ECOLOGY
CENTER. CALIFORNIA FOR FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK, AND UFCW
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME
IS EDDIE SANCHEZ AND I AM A WIFE
OF A FARM WORKER. I SUPPORT AB
1864. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. HI,
MY NAME IS MAYA CASTILLO AND I
SUPPORT AB 1864. THANK YOU.
HOLA. MY NAME IS SANDRA GARCIA.
I OPPOSE VAMOS A VER. CUATRO. YO
SOY APOYANDO PORQUE ME MADRE
MURIO POR LOS PESTICIDES CON
TANTA FUMIGATION. GARCIA EN EL
FIELD. ENTONCES ES MUY
IMPORTANTE QUÊ PONGAN MUCH
ATTENTION PARA LOS NINOS. MUCHAS
GRACIAS. MUCHAS GRACIAS. MI
NOMBRE ES NADA PICASSO. VENGO
VENGO APOYANDO. CUATRO ACERCA DE
PESTICIDES Y CAÑADA MAS
FUMIGATIONS. MUCHAS GRACIAS.
BUENOS DIAS. MY NAME IS MARTHA
LEÓN. BINGO DE FRESNO,
CALIFORNIA. Y APOYO AB DICIEMBRE
DE CUATRO Y ME GUSTARIA C¯ NOS
ESCUCHAR PORQUE INTENCIÓN ME
CASA MINUTOS ME NINOS. YO
TENEMOS MUCHAS GRACIAS. GRACIAS.
MY NAME IS LUPE RASCON AND I
AGREE WITH ALL THESE PEOPLE. WE
NEED THE PROTECTION OF OUR
CHILDREN AND FOR SCHOOL TEACHERS
AND EVEN YOU GUYS. THANK YOU FOR
THE VOICE AND YOU ARE THE POWER.
OKAY. THANK YOU AND GOD BLESS
YOU GUYS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAÑADA MONTES VENGO
DE FRESNO APOYO. MUCHAS GRACIAS.
MY NAME IS ANTONIO MONTES DE
APOYO. LOS CINCO Y MUCHOS
GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. YO VENGO
DESDE FRESNO E APOYO A LA MEDIDA
DE SANTÉ. CUATRO NØ MAS
PESTICIDES IN MY AREA. MIS NINOS
PERSONAS MÉDICOS ES UN PROBLEMA
GRANDISSIMO. MUCHOS GRACIAS. YO
ME LLAMO ARIANI VENGO DE FRESNO.
ESTOY EN CONTRA DE LAS BEBÉS. DE
LAS PESTICIDES IN LA ESCUELA.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. BUENOS DIAS. MIS
NOMBRE ES SARAH SANABRIA. MINGO
DE FRESNO, CALIFORNIA. VENGO AN
APOYO DE LA ESTÁ DE CUATRO
PORQUE MIS HIJOS SON ASTHMATIC
CASI ESTE ANO A TODA LA FAMILIA
NOS FUE MUY MAL EN LAS ALERGIAS.
ESPERO C¯, POR FAVOR, NOS
APOYAN. GRACIAS, GRACIAS. BUENOS
DIAS. SOY FRANCISCO ALVARADO Y
VENGO DE FRESNO, CALIFORNIA.
APOYO A LA CIENCIA DE ABC 60
CUATRO Y CAÑADA MAS INTENCIÓN
LAS ESCUELAS CERCA DE DONDE
VIVIMOS GRACIAS, GRACIAS. ME
NOMBRE ES MARIBEL VENGO DE
FRESNO, CALIFORNIA. E BENGO,
APOYAR A LA VISION DE CUATRO
PARA C¯ NÓI GÓMEZ LAS ESCUELAS.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. ME NOMBRE ES
CELESTE VENGO DE FRESNO E ESTÁN
APOYO DE DICIEMBRE DE CUATRO.
GRACIAS HI, MY NAME IS KAYLEE
AND I'M 14 YEARS OLD, AND I'M
HERE FROM FRESNO, AND I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE AB 1864. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS FREEMAN
SALAS. I COME FROM FRESNO AND I
SUPPORT THE INITIATIVE THAT
ABOUT TAKING ALL THAT POISON
AWAY FROM THE SCHOOLS. AND
THAT'S ABOUT ALL. THANK YOU.
HAVE A GOOD DAY. HELLO. MY NAME
IS MAGGIE. I'M HERE TO SUPPORT,
AB 1864. AND, ALSO, I WANT TO
TELL YOU GUYS THAT THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US BECAUSE
OUR KIDS ARE GETTING SICK,
BECAUSE WE HAVE PESTICIDES CLOSE
TO OUR HOUSE AND SCHOOLS. SO
HUB, GET TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. BUENOS DIAS. A TODOS ME
NOMBRE ES LILIA BIXEL VENGO DE
FRESNO, CALIFORNIA DE LA
ORGANIZACION FAMILIAS IN ACTION
IN COLABORANDO CON OTRAS
ORGANIZACIONES EN CONTRA DE LOS
PESTICIDES EN NUESTROS ESCUELAS.
GRACIAS, GRACIAS. OKAY OKAY.
SEEING NO OTHERS. ONE MORE. ALL
RIGHT. WE GOT A FEW MORE. COME
ON UP. GOOD MORNING. I'M KELLY
GARCIA WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
REFORM AND ON BEHALF OF IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE SAFE ACT SAFE SCHOOLS
COALITION ADVOCATING FOR
PESTICIDE SAFETY, TULARE COUNTY,
AS WELL AS THE PRAXIS PROJECT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YANELLI
MARTINEZ, GREENFIELD CITY
COUNCILWOMAN, IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB 1864. ALSO, COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM. AND I'M ALSO
GOING TO NAME A FEW OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WHO I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION, CALPIRG, OUR
LOBBYIST, REBECCA MARCUS, BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS,
ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP AND THE SUNFLOWER
ALLIANCE, AND FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY. SEEING OR DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
WE'RE GOING TO WRAP UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT. HELLO. MY NAME IS RAUL
GARCIA. I'M FROM PORTERVILLE,
CALIFORNIA IN TULARE COUNTY, I
AM HERE ON THE BEHALF OF THE
COALITION ADVOCATING FOR
PESTICIDE SAFETY AND ON THE
BEHALF OF THE WEST BERKELEY
ALLIANCE FOR CLEAN AIR AND SAFE
JOBS. THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, THE CLEAN WATER
ACTION, THE MONTEREY BAY CENTRAL
LABOR COUNCIL, AND THE PEOPLE
FOR CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN WATER OF
KETTLEMAN CITY. WE ALL SUPPORT,
AB 1864. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. SEEING NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE, WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY LEADS? NO, JUST
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR TAYLOR
OCEAN, REPRESENTING A COALITION
OF AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS.
WE'RE VERY GLAD TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND I
WANT TO THANK MR. CONNELLY AND
PARTICULARLY HIS STAFF. MISS
WOODWARD, FOR WORKING WITH US
ALONG WITH THE SPONSORS. THERE'S
STILL AN OUTSTANDING PIECE
RELATED TO GIS DATA, AND I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THE
JUSTIFICATION BEHIND THAT. CDE
AT THIS POINT, ALONG WITH COUNTY
AG COMMISSIONERS AND GROWERS
THEMSELVES, DON'T KNOW WHERE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE AT, SO
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE EXACT
LOCATIONS OF THEM SO THAT WE CAN
DRAW ACCURATE QUARTER MILE RADII
AND KNOW WHEN AND WHEN WE SUBMIT
A NOTICE OF INTENT AND WHEN WE
DON'T, IS CRITICAL. BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THANK THE STAFF, ANY
OTHERS IN THIS ROOM IN
OPPOSITION OR. YEAH. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS REARDON,
CALIFORNIA FARM. BILL, WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR, AS
WELL, IN TERMS OF OPEN
MINDEDNESS TO WORKING WITH US ON
THIS LEGISLATION. SO WE ALSO
WILL REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO REMOVING
OPPOSITION. THANK THE AUTHOR.
GOOD MORNING, BRENDA BASS WITH
KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AND WE ARE ALSO
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DENNIS ALBIANI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SEED ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA PEAR GROWERS,
CALIFORNIA WHEAT GROWERS,
SEVERAL OTHER AG ASSOCIATIONS,
WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE,
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF. THANK YOU.
WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, GOOD MORNING, MATTHEW
WILDER WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION, A LINE SIMILAR
COMMENTS. WE APPRECIATE THE WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND STAFF AND
REMOVE WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPOSITION THAT
HAS BEEN REMOVED. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IN THIS
ROOM? OKAY. SEEING NONE, I'LL GO
AHEAD AND BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY. I'LL GO AHEAD.
AT THIS MOMENT, BEFORE I SAY A
FEW WORDS, WE'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO,
ASSISTANT, IF YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS HURTADO HERE,
HURTADO HERE. GROVE ALVARADO.
GIL. CORTEZ CORTEZ HERE.
PADILLA. I PRESENT PADILLA
PRESENT. OKAY. QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. OKAY AGAIN, ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS
MEASURE, SENATOR CORTEZ? MADAM
CHAIR, LET ME JUST THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND OBVIOUSLY WORKING
SO HARD TO GET TO CONSENSUS ON
SUCH AN IMPORTANT BILL. HAVING
BEEN RAISED IN THE OLD SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WHERE THERE WERE,
YOU KNOW, NINE HOUSES IN MY AREA
IN A RADIUS OF ABOUT FOUR MILES,
IN AN ORCHARD FARMING COMMUNITY
WITH THE ONLY PUBLIC SCHOOL,
ESSENTIALLY RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THAT ENVIRONMENT, THIS WAS A
COMMON ISSUE, A VERY COMMON
ISSUE. NOT NOT ONLY COMMON, BUT
VISIBLY IN THOSE DAYS. ALSO AS
SOME OF THE FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE HERE KNOW, IN THE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM, WE WERE ALSO
DEALING WITH PARATHION AND DDT
AND THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW HOW IMPACTFUL THEY ARE, AND
KIDS WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE,
EVIDENCE OF, OF SPRAY THAT HAD
DRIFTED, YOU KNOW, FROM THOSE
BIG SPRAY RIGS, YOU KNOW, ON
THEIR, ON THEIR BODIES SHORT
SLEEVE SHIRTS AND ARMS, YOU
KNOW, SORT OF FRECKLED WITH
SPRAY MATERIAL. I SAY THAT AS
SOMEONE WHOSE FAMILY WERE CAME
FROM BOTH A FARM WORKER AND AN
AGRICULTURAL ORCHARD FARMING
BACKGROUND. SO I IT'S TOO LATE
TO BLAME PEOPLE FOR IT. IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF TRYING TO MAKE
THINGS SAFE FOR KIDS. SO I JUST
WANTED TO, INDICATE MY
SOLIDARITY WITH WHAT THE AUTHOR
ATTEMPTED TO DO HERE AND WHAT
THE COMMITTEE DID TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
ASSEMBLY MACAULAY, I YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE FROM
FRESNO. AS YOU KNOW, I WAS BORN
IN FRESNO, SO IT'S GREAT TO SEE
EVERYONE HERE, TO COME OUT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD. OBVIOUSLY A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE. THE OTHER
THING THAT THAT, OF COURSE, IS I
NOTICED IS YOU KNOW, THE YOUNG
KIDS. AND IT MADE ME IT MADE ME
THINK OF MY LITTLE, MY LITTLE
NIECE. SHE'S SIX YEARS OLD.
SHE'S IN SCHOOL. AND, I THINK
THIS BILL WOULD, OBVIOUSLY HELP.
NOT JUST HER, BUT HER CLASSMATES
AS WELL. AND SO I AGAIN, I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. AND
WITH YOUR PERMISSION, I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD AS A AS A COAUTHOR
TO THIS BILL. AND, WITH THAT,
I'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND LEAVE IT
UP TO YOU TO CLOSE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO. YEAH. NO HONORED BY YOUR
SUPPORT. THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK YOU SAID IT
WELL, AND I WANT TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO REALLY
SPEARHEADED THIS EFFORT, THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO SHOWED UP,
THAT'S REALLY WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS. AND ALSO FOR ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT REALLY CAME
TOGETHER ON THIS BILL WAS, GREAT
TO WORK WITH EVERYONE ON THIS
AND REALLY APPRECIATE IT. WITH
THAT, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THANK YOU. GIVEN THAT
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED QUORUM, DO
WE HAVE A MOTION? WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THIS BILL,
ASSISTANT, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLE FILE ITEM ONE? THE
MOTIONS ON FILE ITEM ONE, AB
1864 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. ASSEMBLY
SENATORS HURTADO I, HURTADO I
GROVE. ALVARADO. GILL CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I. PADILLA. PADILLA I
CALL OKAY THE VOTE. THAT MEASURE
HAS THREE VOTES, AND WE'LL PLACE
THAT BILL ON CALL TO ALLOW
OTHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
THANK YOU. WE WILL AT THIS TIME
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO, ASSISTANT, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? I'LL MOVE. YES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WAS MOVED BY
SENATOR PADILLA. WE, THERE ARE
TWO ITEMS. FILE ITEMS THREE AND
FIVE, ABS 23, 24 AND 2721.
SENATORS HURTADO I, HURTADO I
GROVE, ALVARADO. GILL. CORTEZ
CORTEZ I. PADILLA I. PADILLA I
OKAY, WE'LL PLACE THOSE ITEMS ON
CALL. OKAY. UP NEXT WE HAVE,
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN, PLEASE
COME UP AND FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
AB 1963 WHEN YOU ARE READY. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
PARAQUAT FIRST MANUFACTURED IN
1962, IS A HIGHLY TOXIC
HERBICIDE OR WEED KILLER USED ON
ALMONDS, PISTACHIOS AND WALNUT
ORCHARDS AND ON GRAPES AND
COTTON. PARAQUAT IS SPRAYED TO
BURN DOWN OR CLEAR FIELDS BEFORE
PLANTING AND THROUGHOUT THE
GROWING SEASON TO MANAGE WEEDS
BETWEEN CROP ROWS. MUCH OF THE
CHEMICAL ENDS UP IN THE SOIL FOR
YEARS, AND IT CAN EVENTUALLY
REACH NEARBY COMMUNITIES VIA IN
DUST OR DRIFT. WHEN STRONG WINDS
OCCUR. THIS POSES AN INCREASED
RISK TO PEOPLE LIVING AND
WORKING NEAR FIELDS WHO ARE
EXPOSED TO PARAQUAT. HOWEVER,
THE PEOPLE MOST AT RISK OF
PARAQUAT EXPOSURE ARE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WHO MIX,
LOAD AND APPLY PARAQUAT OR ENTER
PARAQUAT AFTER IT'S BEEN
APPLIED. RECENT COMMON PEER
REVIEWED SCIENCE HAS CONFIRMED
THAT EXPOSURE TO PARAQUAT
GREATLY INCREASES THE RISK OF
DEVELOPING PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
PARAQUAT IS BANNED IN MORE THAN
60 COUNTRIES, INCLUDING THOSE
WITH LARGE AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES LIKE THE UNITED
KINGDOM, CHINA, BRAZIL AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE EUROPEAN UNION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOLLOW THEIR
LEAD. WHY SHOULD WE CONTINUE TO
USE THIS PESTICIDE THAT'S BEEN
AROUND SINCE 1962 AND BANNED IN
MANY COUNTRIES, INCLUDING THE
ONES WHO MANUFACTURE IT? WE CAN
DO BETTER BECAUSE ALTERNATIVES
TO PARAQUAT EXIST TODAY AND ARE
USED IN THOSE COUNTRIES VERY
SUCCESSFULLY. ON MONDAY, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 2113 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. THE BILL
RAISES THE MILL ASSESSMENT TO
PROVIDE DPR WITH ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO TAKE ON MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC, AS SOON AS THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS IT, DPR CAN BEGIN HIRING
NEW STAFF. THE BILL DIRECTS DPR
TO PRIORITIZE HIRING IN THE
REGISTRATION BRANCH.
REEVALUATIONS ARE DONE OUT OF
THIS BRANCH. ALSO, THE BILL
REQUIRES DPR TO INITIATE AT
LEAST ONE REEVALUATION A YEAR
UNTIL 2029 AND THEN TWO
REEVALUATIONS A YEAR STARTING IN
2030. THESE REQUIREMENTS MEAN
THEY WILL NEED TO PRIORITIZE
HIRING FOR BOTH REGISTRATION AND
REEVALUATIONS. CALIFORNIA'S DPR
IS EMPHASIZING THAT WE NEED TO
BE USING LESS PESTICIDES AND
HERBICIDES, AND THEIR NEW
PLANNING EFFORT, TITLED
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT. I
AGREE WITH THEM THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO BE THE LEADER IN
ELIMINATING HIGHLY TOXIC
PESTICIDES LIKE PARAQUAT.
FURTHERMORE, THE PESTICIDE
INDUSTRY, ALWAYS PROUD OF THEIR
ABILITY TO INNOVATE, SHOULD STEP
FORWARD AND AGREE TO STOP
PRODUCING THIS PRODUCT AND
PRODUCE FAR LESS TOXIC WASTE.
WEEDKILLERS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS BILL ALLARD
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP AND DOLORES HUERTA,
PRESIDENT OF THE DOLORES HUERTA
FOUNDATION AND AFTER MY
WITNESSES SPEAK, I WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON, IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU OR I CAN DO IT
NOW, WHICHEVER YOU PREFER. OKAY.
THANK YOU. Ó. GOOD MORNING.
BILL ALEO WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP, THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. I'LL JUST SUMMARIZE
THAT THERE IS ROBUST SCIENCE
ABOUT THE HARMS THAT PARAQUAT
CAN HAVE, LET ME SAY THE
OPPONENTS ARE SAYING THERE'S NO
PROOF THAT PARAQUAT CAUSES
PARKINSON'S DISEASE. BUT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CAUSE AND
CORRELATION. LIKE WE'VE HEARD
PEOPLE SAY, MY GRANDFATHER
SMOKED TO 95 AND NEVER GOT LUNG
CANCER, BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN
THERE'S NOT A PROVEN CORRELATION
BETWEEN SMOKING AND LUNG CANCER.
AND 2019 META ANALYSIS. THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR SUMMARIZING THE
SCIENCE ON A PARTICULAR TOPIC
FOUND ACROSS 13 STUDIES.
OCCUPATIONAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURE TO PARAQUAT INCREASED
THE RISK OF DEVELOPING
DEVELOPING PARKINSON'S BY 64
DEGREES, 64. CALIFORNIA DPR AND
PARAQUAT MANUFACTURERS CLAIM
THAT PARAQUAT CAN BE SAFELY USED
WITH PROPER RESTRICTIONS, AND
THAT IT'S A HIGHLY RESTRICTED
USE PESTICIDE, BUT EWG JUST
COMPLETED A SURVEY OF VIOLATIONS
LOGGED BY THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS IN
THE FIVE COUNTIES WHERE PARAQUAT
IS MOST HEAVILY USED, KERN, KING
, FRESNO, TULARE AND MERCED. WE
FOUND 40 VIOLATIONS REPORTED
BETWEEN 2017 AND 2022, AND
DESPITE DPR ADDING MORE USE
RESTRICTIONS EVERY YEAR IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS, ACCIDENTS HAPPEN
AND MISUSE HAPPENS. SO JUST TO
SAY IT'S HIGHLY RESTRICTED
DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T GET
EXPOSED. SO YOU RETIRE AND YEARS
LATER YOU HAVE PARKINSON'S. WAS
IT THE CAUSE? WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE, BUT THIS IS A HIGHLY TOXIC
PESTICIDE THAT WE THINK WE CAN
DO WITHOUT, AB 1963 IS
STRUCTURED SO THAT IT LETS DPR
RETAIN THEIR ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHAT ACTION THEY WILL TAKE AFTER
COMPLETION OF A REEVALUATION OF
PARAQUAT. SO WE'LL LIVE WITH
WHATEVER THEY CHOOSE AS A MORE
RESTRICTIONS, SUSPENSION OR
BUSINESS AS USUAL. WHAT AB 1963
DOES IS LET DPR HEAR FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT THEY NEED AN
EXPEDITIOUS REVIEW OF THIS
HIGHLY TOXIC PESTICIDE. THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS DOLORES
HUERTA, AND WITH THE DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION, I ACTUALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT PARAQUAT
ALSO. FIRST OF ALL, I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT MANY OF THE
PESTICIDES THAT WE USE TODAY, IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES, WERE DEVELOPED DURING IN
GERMANY. ACTUALLY, BEFORE THAT,
THERE WAS NOT A BIG USE OF
PESTICIDE IN OUR COUNTRY, WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
ORGANIC FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT DO NOT USE PESTICIDES. SO
WE CAN'T SAY THAT THERE IS NOT
AN ALTERNATIVE. YOU KNOW, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST CANCER RATE OF
ANY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD. AND I
DO THINK A LOT OF THIS DOES COME
FROM THE USE OF THESE HERBICIDES
AND PESTICIDES. SO WE KNOW THAT,
PARAQUAT IS BANNED ON GOLF
COURSES, BUT IT'S NOT BANNED IN
OUR FARMS FOR THE WORKERS THAT
ACTUALLY FEED THE GOLFERS.
RIGHT. AND I DON'T KNOW, WE CAN
SAY THAT A PERSON THAT PLAYS
GOLF, IF THEIR LIFE IS MORE
VALUABLE THAN A PERSON WHO'S A
FARM WORKER THAT FEEDS ALL OF
US. AND I THINK THAT THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HAS GOT TO
DO A LOT MORE WORK IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY PRODUCE THE
FOOD, THAT ACTUALLY HELPS THEM
GROW THEIR INDUSTRY AND ACTUALLY
HELPS THEM CREATE THE WEALTH
THAT THEY HAVE. SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY TO THE COMMITTEE HERE,
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE. WE
KNOW THAT MANY FARM WORKERS HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES FROM PESTICIDES
AND HERBICIDES LIKE PARAQUAT,
AND WE SAW MANY OF THEM HERE IN
THIS ROOM A LITTLE WHILE AGO,
ALSO TESTIFYING HOW MEMBERS OF
THEIR FAMILY HAVE DIED FROM SOME
OF THE USES OF THESE PESTICIDES.
SO THIS TO ME, THIS IS A MATTER
OF LIFE AND DEATH. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU REALLY HAVE
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. SO I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMAN
FRIEDMAN FOR DOING FOR
PRESENTING THIS LEGISLATION. AND
I HOPE THAT THE REST OF YOU TAKE
IT VERY SERIOUSLY. THANK YOU. SO
I JUST WANTED TO TAKE A MINUTE
TO DISCUSS THE AMENDMENTS AND TO
OUTLINE WHERE WE ARE. SO I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
WILLINGNESS TO SIT DOWN WITH US
ON FRIDAY TO TRY TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ABOUT AMENDMENTS. THE
COMMITTEE WAS NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT THE BILL THAT HAD COME
TO THIS COMMITTEE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE, WHICH PUT IN PLACE
A MORATORIUM UNTIL DPR COULD DO
THEIR REEVALUATION. SO WHAT WE
AGREED TO ON FRIDAY WAS TO
REMOVE THE MORATORIUM ON
PARAQUAT AND TO ALLOW THE
CONTINUED USE OF PARAQUAT UNTIL
2028 TO SAY THAT DPR SHOULD
FINISH THEIR EVALUATION IN 2028,
AND WE WOULD LIVE BY WHATEVER
THEY DECIDED IN THAT
REEVALUATION TO BAN THE USE OR
TO CONTINUE THE USE, OR TO
FURTHER RESTRICT THE USE. THAT
WOULD BE UP TO DPR. BUT WE DID
SAY THAT IF THEY HADN'T
COMPLETED BY 2028, WE NEEDED A
MORATORIUM IN PLACE BECAUSE WE
NEEDED TO HAVE A REAL, REAL
REASON FOR THEM TO COMPLETE THE
EVALUATION. OTHERWISE, IT'S MORE
OF A SUGGESTION IF THERE'S NO
SORT OF PENALTY FOR THEM, THEY
COULD JUST CONTINUE
INDEFINITELY. YESTERDAY WE WERE
TOLD THAT THE COMMITTEE WAS NOW
NO LONGER COMFORTABLE WITH
HAVING THAT MORATORIUM AND ALSO
THE DATE OF 2028. AND WANTED TO
PUSH THE DATE TO 2029 WITH NO
MORATORIUM. IF DPR FAILED TO
FINISH THEIR REVIEW. WE ARE
FULLY ACCEPTING OF PUSHING THE
DATE TO 2029. WE'D RATHER THEY,
YOU KNOW, COMPLETE EARLIER, BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY LIVE WITH 2029.
BUT WE DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RETAIN THAT MORATORIUM SHOULD
THEY FAIL TO COMPLETE THEIR
REEVALUATION. OTHERWISE THERE'S
NOTHING TO PREVENT THEM FROM
SIMPLY STALLING FOR ANOTHER TEN
YEARS OR FROM FAILING TO
COMPLETE. THERE'S NO PROTECTION
IN THERE FOR THE WORKERS WHO ARE
RIGHT NOW, AS YOU HEARD, GETTING
PARKINSON'S DISEASE AT A RATE
ALMOST TWICE THAT OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. SO WE THINK THAT
IT'S REALLY IT'S REASONABLE TO
SAY, CONTINUE TO USE THE
CHEMICAL UNTIL 2029. DPR FINISH
YOUR REVIEW. WE WILL LIVE BY
THAT REVIEW. BUT IF YOU HAVEN'T
FINISHED, PUT THE TEMPORARY
MORATORIUM IN PLACE UNTIL THE
REVIEW IS FINISHED. AND SO THAT
IS THE BILL THAT WE ARE
PRESENTING AND THAT WE WOULD
LIKE YOU TO VOTE ON TODAY. THANK
YOU, WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IN THIS ROOM. SO FOR
ANYONE.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT'S ON
YET. THEY'RE PUTTING IT ON
YESTERDAY. THE WAY. NØ. TESTING.
TESTING GOOD. OKAY. JANE.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM. WE CAME
INTENDING TO SUPPORT, BUT WE DO
NOT SUPPORT WITHOUT FIRM
DEADLINES FROM DPR. I JUST WANT
TO NOTE THAT DPR PRIORITIZED
PARAQUAT FOR REEVALUATION IN
2011, AND RANKED IT NUMBER TWO
PRIORITY IN 2014 AND HAS NOT
COMPLETED. THEY DO NOT NEED FIVE
YEARS. THEY CERTAINLY DON'T NEED
AN INDEFINITE PERIOD. SO, WE'LL
MOVE TO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. AND JUST PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. USHA
SHARMA, ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, NATE
SOLOVE, ON BEHALF OF THE MICHAEL
J. FOX FOUNDATION FOR
PARKINSON'S RESEARCH AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
JENNA PRICE ON BEHALF OF ENVIRO
VOTERS AND THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
SUPPORT, THANK YOU, MJ KUSHNER
FROM COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT? THERE'S
PEOPLE COMING IN OKAY. YANELLI
MARTINEZ, GREENFIELD CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT.
UNLESS AMENDED. SO, YES. SORRY.
IT'S ALL CRAZY RIGHT NOW WITH
THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU. HELLO
AGAIN. RAUL GARCIA FROM
PORTERVILLE, WITH ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION ADVOCATING FOR
PESTICIDE SAFETY, WE WILL ONLY
SUPPORT THE BILL IF IT IS
AMENDED. AS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY
MY COLLEAGUE, JANE SELLEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME
IS VICTOR TORRES. I'M A
CO-FOUNDER OF FUTURE LEADERS OF
CHANGE. AND ON BEHALF WE ARE IN
SUPPORT IF AMENDED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY MORE SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM? ANY ANY ADDITIONAL?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE INTO ANY. ANYONE
HERE FOR THE LEAD OPPOSITION?
YES, MA'AM. I BELIEVE IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE ME TODAY. YES, GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. TAYLOR ROSHAN, ON
BEHALF OF A VARIETY OF
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS, SO ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN PISTACHIO
GROWERS, AG AIRCRAFT ASSOCIATION
, CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PEST
CONTROL ADVISORS, CALIFORNIA
COTTON GROWERS AND GENERAL
WESTERN AG PROCESSORS, WESTERN
PLANT HELP, APPLE, AVOCADO,
STRAWBERRY AND WALNUT
COMMISSION, CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT COMMISSION ASSOCIATION,
AND MANY MORE, WE OPPOSE THE
BILL IN PRINT, AND WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
WHAT WE THOUGHT WERE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. BUT NOW SEEM TO BE
AMENDED. ORAL AMENDMENTS ON THE
BILL, WELL, IT'S NOT RECOGNIZED
IN THIS BUILDING. OUR MEMBERS
WORK INCREDIBLY HARD TO COMPLY
WITH THE STATE'S PESTICIDE LAWS
THAT ARE THE MOST STRINGENT IN
THE WORLD AND IMPOSE NOT IMPOSED
ON FARMERS ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
UNITED STATES. YOU'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL HEARINGS ABOUT WHY SMALL
FARMERS ARE CLOSING UP SHOP AND
THE INDUSTRY IS CONSOLIDATING.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHY, THE
GOAL POSTS CONTINUE TO MOVE. AND
THE SAME SCIENCES. THAT'S GOOD
ENOUGH TO REVIEW PRODUCT SAFETY
FOR SANITIZERS, CLEANING
MATERIALS, THE THINGS THAT YOU
TOUCH IN YOUR HOMES EVERY DAY
AND ON YOUR FARM FIELD ISN'T
GOOD ENOUGH FOR FARMERS.
NEVERTHELESS, THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS, WE'VE
WORKED HARD TO PROPOSE
AMENDMENTS ON PESTICIDE BILLS
THAT, AT THEIR FOUNDATION,
RESPECT THE DEPARTMENT'S
SCIENTIFIC PROCESS, I THINK MR.
CONNELLY'S BILL IS AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT HARD WORK. AB 1963. AND NOW
WITH THESE POTENTIAL NEW
AMENDMENTS, THEY DO NOT RESPECT
THE PROCESS. THE DEPARTMENT IS
IN THE PROCESS OF COMPLETING AN
INITIAL SCIENTIFIC ASSESSMENT TO
REVIEW THE DATA THAT EXISTS, TO
DETERMINE IF THERE IS MERIT TO
PURSUE FURTHER ACTION. THEY HAVE
TOLD US AND THE COMMITTEE THEY
EXPECT TO FINISH THIS WORK IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS, BUT RATHER
ALLOW THAT PROCESS MOVE FORWARD,
THE BILL WOULD OBLIGATE A
REEVALUATION AND THEN SET A
COMPLETELY UNACHIEVABLE TIMELINE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO ACTUALLY
CONSIDER THE COMPLETION OF A
REEVALUATION. WE BELIEVE THROUGH
THE EXISTING PROCESS, THE
DEPARTMENT CAN DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT A REEVALUATION IS
WARRANTED. IF MORE DATA IS
NEEDED, OR IF NO ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE
STIPULATED. BUT RATHER THAN THIS
PROCESS PLAY THROUGH SUPERVISED
BY SCIENTISTS AND TOXICOLOGISTS
AND HUMAN HEALTH SPECIALISTS,
THIS BILL AND THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS SUGGEST THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ALREADY KNOW
THE OUTCOME. THIS NOT ONLY
REPRESENTS A THUMB ON THE SCALE
OF SCIENCE, IT THROWS THE SCALE
OUT. AND WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF A MANDATORY
REEVALUATION ON PARAQUAT? ON ITS
FACE ALONE, IT MEANS THE
DEPARTMENT IS WASTING RESOURCES
AND TIME REEVALUATING AN ACTIVE
INGREDIENT, EVEN IF THEIR DATA
AND SCIENTIFIC PROCESS DOESN'T
SUBSTANTIATE THAT WORK NEEDS TO
BE DONE. THAT'S RESOURCES THAT
COULD AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
OTHERWISE SPENT ON THE NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY ACTIVE INGREDIENT,
OR OTHER ACTIVE INGREDIENTS LIKE
FUNGICIDES AND FUMIGANTS,
RODENTICIDES AND HERBICIDES THAT
HAVE NOT HAD REGULATORY ACTION
EVERY YEAR FOR FOUR YEARS, LIKE
PARAQUAT HAS. I ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY THE SPONSORS.
THERE'S AN ALLEGATION THAT THIS
BILL, THIS PRODUCT, IS BANNED IN
OTHER, OTHER COUNTRIES. THAT'S
BECAUSE OF INCIDENTAL INGESTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
MODIFICATIONS TO DISALLOW THAT
EXPOSURE. THE CAUSAL LINK THAT
WAS SUGGESTED, THAT WASN'T MY
RECOMMENDATION, THAT WASN'T
INDUSTRY'S RECOMMENDATION. THERE
WAS A CAUSAL LINK WITH WITH
PARAQUAT AND PARKINSON'S
DISEASE. USDA MADE A
DETERMINATION IN MARCH OF THIS
YEAR THAT THERE WAS NO CAUSAL
LINK, I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT VIOLATIONS, WE
HAVE NOT SEEN THE DATA TO
SUBSTANTIATE THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF VIOLATIONS. IF
VIOLATIONS ARE OCCURRING WILDLY
IN CALIFORNIA, THAT IS THE BASIS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION. AND THEY HAVE
DONE THAT BEFORE AND OTHER
ACTIVE INGREDIENTS AND THEN
LASTLY, THE COMMENTARY THAT IT'S
BANNED ON GOLF COURSES, IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE FOR USE ON GOLF
COURSES. THE PRODUCT LITERALLY
KILLS ALL PLANT MATERIAL. I
DON'T KNOW, A GOLF COURSE
MANAGER IN THE UNIVERSE WHO
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN WIDELY
APPLYING A PRODUCT THAT KILLS
GREEN MATERIAL WHEN THEIR
LIVELIHOOD IS BASED ON THE
PROMULGATION OF GREEN MATERIAL.
FINALLY, LAST WEEK YOU VOTED OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND APPROVED
ON THE FLOOR AB 2113, WHICH DOES
INCLUDE A SIGNIFICANT TAX
INCREASE ON FARMERS TO FUND THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO THEIR JOB. I
WANT TO NOTE THE MILL ASSESSMENT
DOES NOT COVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH REEVALUATION.
THAT BILL HOLDS THEM ACCOUNTABLE
TO DELIVERABLES LIKE FASTER
REEVALUATIONS NOT IN THE
UNIVERSE OF THE TIME PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL, AND FASTER
REGISTRATION SO THAT
ALTERNATIVES CAN COME TO BEAR.
AND A PROCESS THAT'S MORE
TRANSPARENT FOR THE PUBLIC. SO
TO HAVE THIS COMMITTEE A WEEK
LATER OVERTURN MONTHS OF DEBATE
AND LEARNING ON HOW TO INVEST,
EXPEDITE, IMPROVE AND DAYLIGHT.
THE PROCESS AT DPR IS VERY
CONCERNING. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE REQUEST A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS,
ORGANIZATION, PLEASE. HELLO,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MATTHEW
ALLEN WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. WE URGE A NO VOTE
ON THE BILL AND ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH MISS ROSHAN. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS,
AARON NORWOOD, ON BEHALF OF THE
ALMOND ALLIANCE, ALSO OPPOSED.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TRICIA
GEHRINGER, WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA, URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. TATUM MCCLURE
WITH SAMPSON ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS IN OPPOSITION. CHRIS.
CHRIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN OPPOSITION. BRENDA
BASS WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. EMILY AUGUSTINE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SEED
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
PEAR GROWERS ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS IN THIS
ROOM IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE,
I WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND I WANT TO START
BY, ADDRESSING THE COMMENTS OF
THE AUTHOR. I KNOW THAT FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING, WE I COMMITTED
TO YOU AND WORKING WITH WORKING
WITH YOU ON THIS BILL TO GET THE
AMENDMENTS JUST RIGHT. IT IS MY
AGREE. IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US TODAY WERE
ACTUALLY SENT OVER BY YOUR BY
YOUR TEAM. AND SO THAT'S, THAT'S
THE LAST, UNDER THAT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE, OF THE, OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE WOULD BE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT, THAT I
COULD SUPPORT HERE TODAY, I, I
FIND IT SURPRISING THAT THERE IS
A CHANGE OF HEART IN TERMS OF
WHERE YOU'RE LOOKING TO GO IN
TERMS OF AMENDMENTS. I WISH THAT
THOSE, CONCERNS WOULD OR THE
CHANGE OF HEART WOULD HAVE CAME
EARLIER. BUT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE AGREED UPON IN GOOD
FAITH WERE SENT OVER BY YOUR BY
YOUR TEAM. YOU AND I SPOKE ON
FRIDAY, AND I THOUGHT THAT WE
HAD WALKED OUT WITH AN AGREEMENT
YESTERDAY. YOUR YOUR STAFF HAD
SENT US REVISIONS TO THOSE
AMENDMENTS, INCLUDING REMOVING
THE MORATORIUM COMPLETELY. OUR
STAFF'S WENT BACK AND FORTH WITH
SORT OF WHAT YOU ALL WERE
THINKING, WHAT WHAT OUR TEAM
WAS, WAS UNDERSTANDING WITHOUT
ANY AGREEMENT. WHEN THIS WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT THE
AGREEMENT THAT I THOUGHT THAT WE
HAD ON FRIDAY WAS NO LONGER
ACCEPTABLE TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU
KNOW, I REVIEWED WHAT HAD BEEN
SENT OVER THE WHAT HAD GONE BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN YOUR YOUR
STAFF AND MY STAFF AND DECIDED
THAT THE MORATORIUM TO REMOVE
THE MORATORIUM AFTER THAT, I WAS
FINE WITH THE MORATORIUM UP
UNTIL THE DATE THEY REVIEWED.
BUT TO ME, TO NOT HAVE IT AFTER
REALLY LEAVES US WITH A BILL
THAT ALL IT DOES IS IT SAYS,
HEY, DPR, TRY TO DO THIS BY 29.
THAT'S ALL THE BILL SAYS RIGHT
NOW THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR TEN YEARS. AT LEAST THEY'VE
BEEN TOLD TO. THEY MOVED THIS UP
TO THE NUMBER ONE OR NUMBER TWO
POSITION OF REVIEW. I DON'T FEEL
THAT THAT PARTICULAR THAT THAT
AMENDMENT THE WAY THAT THAT IT
CHANGED BETWEEN FRIDAY AND
YESTERDAY GIVES US A BILL THAT
HAS ANY REAL TEETH OR ANYTHING
BEYOND BEING ALMOST A RESOLUTION
URGING THEM TO REVIEW MORE
QUICKLY. I THINK WITHOUT HAVING
THE MORATORIUM, IF THEY DON'T
COMPLETE THE WORK BY 29, I'M
FINE WITH PUSHING THE DATE TO
29, BUT OTHERWISE YOU BASICALLY
HAVE A RESOLUTION THAT URGES
THEM TO DO SOMETHING WITHOUT ANY
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
WHATSOEVER, OR ANY CERTAINTY FOR
THE FARM WORKERS, THAT IF THEY
DON'T HAVE A DECISION, THEY
WON'T, THAT THEY'LL BE
PROTECTED. I FEEL THAT THE VERY
LEAST FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
CONCERNS, WHO ARE WORKING ON THE
CROPS, AND WE'VE HAD TESTIMONY
FROM FARMERS, WE HAD A TESTIMONY
FROM A FARMER WHO CAME INTO THE
ASSEMBLY WHO NOW HAS
PARKINSON'S, WHO BELIEVES IT'S
FROM USING PARAQUAT AS
INSTRUCTED OVER THE YEARS, THESE
PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
CERTAINTY OR TO NOT HAVE TO HAVE
TO BE USED THIS PESTICIDE THAT
HAS SUCH A STRONG LINK THAT IT'S
BEEN BANNED IN 64 COUNTRIES. AND
BY THE WAY, IT WAS BANNED ON
GOLF COURSES. GOLF COURSE
OPERATORS DIDN'T JUST DECIDE TO
NOT USE IT. EPA BANNED ITS USE
FOR GOLF COURSES, IN MY MIND,
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THAT THE ONLY
EXPLANATION I CAN SEE IS THAT
THEY FEEL THAT PEOPLE
INTERACTING WITH GOLF COURSES
ARE WORTH MORE THAN PEOPLE
INTERACTING WITH CROPS. I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND NO ONE HAS GIVEN ME
ANY OTHER EXPLANATION AS TO WHY
EPA WENT OUT OF THEIR WAY TO BAN
IT. AS FAR AS I KNOW, FOR GOLF
COURSES. SO, I UNDERSTAND THAT
YESTERDAY THERE WAS A FLURRY OF
EMAILS GOING BACK AND FORTH, BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING WAS WHEN WE
WALKED OUT OF OUR OUR ZOOM ON
FRIDAY, THAT THAT'S WHERE THOSE
WERE, THE AMENDMENTS. OKAY. WELL
YOUR TEAM SHOULD HAVE SAID THAT
INSTEAD OF ENGAGING IN CONTINUED
DIALOG BACK AND FORTH ON. BUT
THEY NEVER LANGUAGE. THERE WAS A
LOT OF LANGUAGE GOING BACK AND
FORTH, BUT THERE WAS NO
AGREEMENT THAT THIS WAS THE SET
OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE
AGREEING TO. THERE WAS A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH AND BACK AND
FORTH THROUGHOUT THE DAY. OKAY.
WELL, DO WE HAVE DO WE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. JUST SOME CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS AND I CERTAINLY SHARE
THE AUTHOR'S OBJECTIVE AND
URGENCY HERE. THIS IS, YOU KNOW,
AGAIN, AND I DON'T WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF THE SCIENTISTS HERE OR
THE EVALUATION, BUT THERE SEEMS
TO BE SOME, AT LEAST
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE, SHALL
WE SAY, THAT THERE ARE PROBLEMS
WITH THIS. AND I DON'T EVEN
BEGIN TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THERE ARE REASONABLE, SAFER
ALTERNATIVES, WHICH IS ANOTHER
PIECE OF THIS EVALUATION. BUT
THERE IS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
THIS IS SOME SOME DETRIMENTAL
STUFF. IF IT'S NOT CONTROLLED
AND REGULATED PROPERLY, LET'S
JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT. SO WE
HAVE A PRELIMINARY EXAM THAT IS
UNDERWAY, NOT FOR THE FIRST
TIME. AND AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
THE AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THAT'S
BEEN PRESENTED TO THE MEMBERS,
WE HAVE A REEVALUATION.
REEVALUATION PURSUANT TO 120 824
THAT IS MUCH BROADER IN SCOPE
AND DEEPER AND INVOLVES A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF ANALYSIS AND
REQUIRED ANALYSIS. AS A MATTER
OF FACT, AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
AND IT'S REITERATED IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT THE DPR HAS BASED
UPON THAT PARTICULAR TYPE OF
REEVALUATION, RECOURSE TO
MAINTAIN, CANCEL OR SUSPEND
REGISTRATION. SO AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THAT EVALUATION
AND THERE'S A SUSPENSION OF
REGISTRATION, WHAT IS THE
PRACTICAL EFFECT OF THE
SUSPENSION OF REGISTRATION?
WELL, AT THAT POINT, I'M
ASSUMING THAT THAT MEANS THAT
THEY WOULD NO LONGER BE ALLOWING
PARAQUAT. AND THAT'S AGAIN,
THAT'S THEIR DETERMINATION. IF
THEY DETERMINE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO ALLOW ITS
USE, THE BILL SAYS THAT'S FINE.
I GUESS WHAT I'M AND I SHARE
YOUR INTENT TO WANT AN
AFFIRMATIVE, PRESCRIPTIVE
LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE THAT
SAYS MORATORIUM. IF THEY FAIL OR
THEY'RE NOT TIMELY AND I DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SEPARATE
QUESTION OF MAKING SURE THE
ANALYSIS IS A CONDUCTED AND DONE
IN IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATUTE. AND I THANK YOU FOR
EVEN MOVING BACK A YEAR. I SHARE
YOUR FRUSTRATION WITH THAT. BUT
I DO TAKE SLIGHT ISSUE WITH THE
ASSERTION THAT THERE ISN'T AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM WHEN THE
WHEN THE STATUTE THAT REGULATES
THIS LEVEL OF EVALUATION ALREADY
PRESCRIBES POTENTIAL COURSES OF
ACTION TO INCLUDE SUSPENDING THE
REGISTRATION SHOULD THAT BE
BORNE OUT IN THE ANALYSIS,
RIGHT? IN OTHER WORDS, NOT
ALLOWING ITS USE, I THINK AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT THE PARTIES
COULD COME TO THAT MEETING
BECAUSE AT A BARE MINIMUM, THIS
LEVEL OF EVALUATION IS NEEDED.
IT IS NEEDED TIMELY. IT IS
HIGHLY VALUABLE TO OBTAIN THIS
DATA BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE LEARNING IS
THAT THE SCIENCE AND THE AND THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THE ANALYSIS
AROUND THIS IS EVOLVING. WE ARE
UNDERSTANDING AND LEARNING
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC. AND, YOU KNOW
, HUMAN HEALTH TODAY IN WAYS WE
DID NOT UNDERSTAND A FEW YEARS
AGO. AND FRANKLY, WE'RE DERELICT
IF WE DON'T RESPOND TO THOSE
BASED ON THE SCIENCE. SO MY HOPE
IS THAT THERE'S A MEETING
BETWEEN THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR THAT WE
CAN AT LEAST GET THIS DATA DONE.
WE HAVE A DATE CERTAIN FOR ITS
COMPLETION. WE ALSO HAVE A
PRESCRIPTION IN THE STATUTE THAT
SAYS IF THE ANALYSIS ITSELF
DETERMINES THAT THERE IS A RISK
TO HUMAN HEALTH, THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SUSPEND IT. AND
OBVIOUSLY, IF THEY'RE DERELICT
IN THAT, IF THEY'RE IGNORING
THEIR OWN SCIENCE AND
EVALUATION, IF THEY'RE SUDDENLY
REPRIORITIZING THE TIMING, IF
THEY'RE OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THE DEADLINE DATE, THE YOU KNOW,
I'M HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTIVE IN
THIS IN THIS BODY, TO TAKE
ACTION LEGISLATIVELY TO ADDRESS
THAT, BECAUSE I, LIKE YOU, DON'T
WANT TO SEE THIS BALL KICK. THIS
CAN KICK DOWN THE ROAD ANY
FURTHER. WE NEED THE ANALYSIS
DONE, AND I FOR ONE, AM NOT
GOING TO, YOU KNOW, BE SOMEONE
WHO WOULD BE WILLING TO SUPPORT
TOLERATING THAT. BUT I'M HOPING
FOR OUR PURPOSES HERE TODAY, WE
CAN GET TO A MEETING OF THE
MINDS SO THAT WE CAN, AT LEAST
MOVE ON WITH THE ANALYSIS AND
THE DATA AND GET IT DONE BY THIS
DEADLINE. I AGREE WITH YOU. I
THINK THIS IS OVERLY GENEROUS IN
TERMS OF THE YEARS BECAUSE OF
THE HISTORY HERE. WE NEED THE
INFORMATION, SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER, BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S AT LEAST
SOME PARTIAL AGREEMENT HERE. SO,
MADAM CHAIR, I HOPE WE CAN GET
THERE. AND THAT WOULD BE MY
SENTIMENTS AND MY QUESTIONS. AND
I THANK YOU. DID YOU WANT TO A
QUICK RESPONSE? OKAY. YES. NO
THANKS. I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND ORIGINALLY THIS
BILL HAD A MORATORIUM UNTIL THEY
COMPLETED THEIR REVIEW. THAT WAS
THAT WAS WHERE WE STARTED WITH
THIS. SO WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY
IN SAYING WE'RE OKAY WITH
KEEPING KEEPING THE CURRENT
STATUS IN EFFECT, EVEN THOUGH
THERE IS SO MUCH CONCERN FROM
THE FARM WORKER COMMUNITY, FROM
OTHERS, FROM PEOPLE WHO LIVE
NEAR THESE FARMS, ETC, BECAUSE
OF THE DRIFT AND ELSEWHERE. BUT
WE'RE WILLING TO TRUST THE
PROCESS AND TRUST DPH'S ANALYSIS
AND TO DEFAULT TO THAT. OUR
CONCERN IS IF THIS DRAGS OUT TO
2035, 2040, THERE'S NO RECOURSE
FOR THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE RIGHT
NOW LIVING WITH PARAQUAT, USING
IT AND CONCERNED THAT'S WHY WE
THOUGHT THAT IT IS FAIR TO SAY
ALL RIGHT, NO MORATORIUM NOW.
BUT AND LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S
GENEROUS TO GO TO 2029. BUT AT
THAT POINT, IF THEY'RE NOT
MOVING, IF, IF FOR WHATEVER
REASON, THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
COMPLETE THIS, WE THINK THAT WE
DO OWE IT TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
USING THIS SUBSTANCE TO HAVE
THAT TEMPORARY MORATORIUM UNTIL
THE SCIENCE IS DONE. BUT WE
TRUST THEIR PROCESS WHEN THEY'VE
FINISHED WHERE THE BILL ACCEPTS
WHATEVER THEIR DECISION IS.
SENATOR CORTESE YEAH, THANK
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, I TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THAT THE
AUTHOR IS BRINGING FORWARD AND
THE SPONSOR BRINGING FORWARD IN
TERMS OF HAVING SOME TEETH, AT
THE END OF THIS 4 OR 5 YEAR
PERIOD, I ALSO UNDERSTAND BEING
A COMMITTEE CHAIR HERE. HOW,
SOMETIMES THE BEST EFFORTS GOING
BACK AND FORTH AND BACK AND
FORTH END UP WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF CONFUSION. I'VE HAD THAT
HAPPEN RECENTLY, AND I WON'T GET
INTO THAT, IN MY OWN COMMITTEE.
AND WE'RE FORTUNATELY, IN THAT
CASE, ABLE THE DAY OF TO GET A
TERM SHEET PUT TOGETHER IN
WRITING THAT WASN'T OBVIOUSLY
WHAT HAPPENED HERE, LET ME JUST
MAKE TWO POINTS. ONE ON ON
PROCEDURE GOING FORWARD AND ONE
ON MY GENERAL CONCERN ABOUT
ABOUT PARAQUAT. I THINK PART OF
THE REASON WE NEED THIS STUDY IS
BECAUSE I THINK SOME OF THIS
STUFF THAT'S OUT THERE AND AS
AGAIN, AS, AS SOMEONE WHO GREW
UP WITH THIS, WE USED TO JUST
CALL IT SPRAY MATERIAL. YOU KNOW
WHAT IT DOES SOMETIMES I BELIEVE
NOT A DOCTOR. I'M JUST GOING BY
WHAT I'VE SEEN OVER A LOT OF
YEARS AND WHAT I SEE HAPPENING
TO PEOPLE IN MY OWN FAMILY AT
THIS POINT IS THAT WE HAVE
SYMPTOMS THAT MIMIC MIMIC
PARKINSON'S. IT'S HORRIBLE
SYMPTOMS, AND DOCTORS START
GOING DOWN THAT PATH, YOU KNOW,
TRYING TO PRESCRIBE CARE. BUT,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE IN THAT IN THAT
AREA SOMETIMES MEDICALLY WHERE
IT'S NOT REALLY PARKINSON'S.
IT'S SOMETHING VERY, VERY
SIMILAR AND JUST AS DEVASTATING
TO THE HUMAN BEING BECAUSE IT
WAS CREATED, YOU KNOW,
INTRODUCED INTO THE NERVE SYSTEM
, BY, BY THIS KIND OF MATERIAL
AS OPPOSED TO, YOU KNOW, THROUGH
SOME OTHER PROCESS OR SOME OTHER
GENETIC CAUSE THAT SAID, I ALL
THE MORE REASON WE NEED THIS
DONE AND WE NEED IT DONE. RIGHT.
AND FRANKLY, IF THERE'S A LACK
OF DETERMINATION IN TERMS OF
ACTUAL CAUSE AND EFFECT TO ME,
BUT WE HAVE ALL THIS ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE. IT'S A GREAT REASON
FOR A MORATORIUM, NOT
NECESSARILY A BAN, BUT A
MORATORIUM UNTIL PEOPLE CAN
FIGURE IT OUT. OTHERWISE, WE'RE
LITERALLY KILLING PEOPLE,
MAIMING PEOPLE, AND DESTROYING
THEIR NERVE, POTENTIALLY
DESTROYING THEIR CENTRAL NERVOUS
SYSTEM. I MEAN, THAT'S THE REAL
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY AT STAKE
HERE, AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
JUST FARM WORKERS. I THINK IT'S
EVERYBODY WHO WORKS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT, INCLUDING FARMERS
THEMSELVES. YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS THAT CAME OUT OF
THE MOVEMENT BACK IN THE DAY
WAS, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WERE NO
LONGER GOING TO THE STORE WHO
WERE NOT FARMERS OR FARM WORKERS
BUYING APPLES WITH, DDT AND
PARATHION ON THEM BECAUSE IT WAS
THE FARM WORKER MOVEMENT THAT
CAME FORWARD AND SORT OF BLEW
THE WHISTLE ON THAT AND SAID,
OUR PEOPLE ARE DYING IN THE
FIELDS. THE REST OF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE DYING FROM EATING
THIS STUFF BECAUSE NOBODY WASHES
IT. THEY PICK IT UP, RIGHT
DIRECTLY FROM THE GROCERY STORE
AND INGEST IT. IT'S NOT GOOD,
GOING FORWARD, MADAM CHAIR, I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO PERHAPS HAVE
YOU CONSIDER. I MEAN, WE'RE IN
THIS SITUATION WHERE IF WE DON'T
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD, IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE AUTHOR DOESN'T
HAVE A CHANCE TO KEEP PROCESSING
HERE, THE REST OF SESSION AND
TRY TO GET SOME TEETH INTO THIS.
MAYBE IT'S NOT MORATORIUM. MAYBE
IT'S SOME OTHER FASHION OF
PUTTING SOME TEETH INTO IT THAT
THE AUTHOR CAN COME BACK WITH.
AND I WOULD JUST WONDER IF THE
CHAIR WOULD BE WILLING TO ASSIST
WITH THAT PIECE OF IT GOING
FORWARD. BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF HERE HAS SOME REAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS. AND
EXPERTISE IN THIS. AND, I WOULD
RATHER NOT SEE US AS A
COMMITTEE. JUST MY $0.02. I
DEFER TO THE CHAIR, BUT, YOU
KNOW, TO CALL BACK, YOU KNOW,
SOME REMEDY OR SOME, ABILITY
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS YOU KNOW, TO
PUT SOME TEETH INTO THIS, IN THE
FUTURE, IF THERE'S AGREEMENT
GOING FORWARD, IT GIVES EVERYONE
A LITTLE TIME TO SORT OF UNRAVEL
ALL THESE EMAILS AND EVERYTHING
THAT WENT BACK AND FORTH AS
WELL. AND I THINK IF WE CAN DO
THAT, WE CAN MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD. AND, MADAM CHAIR, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO YOU, JUST
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
CONVERSATION ON WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE END OF FIVE YEARS GETS TO
CONTINUE UNTIL THIS BILL GETS TO
THE FLOOR, THAT'S MY SUGGESTION.
ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN, THE AUTHOR,
I MEAN, I COMMITTED TO HER FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING THAT I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND OF COURSE,
I, I LIVE IN BAKERSFIELD. I MY
ENTIRE FAMILY LIVES IN THE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT, I DON'T TAKE
LIGHTLY. I WANT TO, I WANT TO I
FEEL LIKE I HAVE BEEN HONEST,
TRANSPARENT AND, AS FAIR AS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS,
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD. I
UNDERSTAND IT. LOOK, WE WOULD
ALL LIKE THINGS TO BE EXPEDITED,
RIGHT? AND MOVED ALONG A LITTLE
BIT FASTER. AND, AND, BUT, YOU
KNOW, WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE CASE, RIGHT NOW
WITH, WITH, TRYING TO GET
REEVALUATIONS DONE. SO, I FELT
THAT THE AMENDMENTS AT HAND HAD,
TEETH TO HOLD DPR ACCOUNTABLE TO
DOING A REEVALUATION OF PARAQUAT
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT, I DO
FEEL THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY AS
A, AS A, YOU KNOW, AS A
LEGISLATURE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT. IF THIS
BILL YOU KNOW, GETS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND SIGNED, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I AGAIN, I DON'T
I DON'T TAKE LIGHTLY. SO THANK
YOU. I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND SHARING THAT. I
THINK WE ALL HAVE THE SAME GOAL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THERE'S A, YOU KNOW, A CAUSE
HERE AND A RISK HERE, YOU KNOW,
AND THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT OF
EVIDENCE THAT WE GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THAT AND MAKE SURE
WE'RE PROTECTIVE AND WE WANT IT
TO BE REALISTIC TO, YOU KNOW,
DPR HAS HAD TWO PESTICIDES UNDER
INVESTIGATION, ONE SINCE 1998
AND ONE SINCE 2003. SO I
UNDERSTAND WE ARE INCREASING THE
FUNDING AND WE'RE TRYING TO HELP
WITH THAT, AND I, I, I REALLY
APPRECIATE, YOU KNOW, ALL OF
YOUR, YOUR COMMENTS, YOU KNOW,
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THE EXPEDITED REVIEW THAT WE
NEED AND THAT WE GIVE SOME
CERTAINTY TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
USING THIS CHEMICAL AND WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT, THAT IF IT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, THAT THEY
HAVE SOME RELIEF. AND I'M
CERTAINLY WILLING TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSING WITH THE CHAIR. AND
THE CHAIR HAS DEFINITELY ACTED
IN GOOD FAITH AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
TALK TO US ON A FRIDAY AND GET
EVERYONE ON A ZOOM WITH YOUR
WHOLE STAFF. I APPRECIATE THAT,
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO TALK
WITH YOU. AND HOPEFULLY BY THE
TIME THIS GETS TO THE FLOOR, WE
HAVE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON. OKAY, SO WHAT DID.
TRYING TO FIGURE IF YOU COULD
JUST BEAR WITH ME FOR PROCEDURE
PURPOSES. I AM SORRY FOR THE
CONFUSION. IT'S A CRAZY TIME OF
YEAR.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE
A QUICK RECESS. SURE. RIGHT.
OKAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE IS GOING TO COME
BACK TO ORDER. OKAY, SO WE'RE IN
THE MATTER OF, AB 1963 FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. WE PROVIDED THE
AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE,
YOU KNOW, AS CHAIR FOR THE
SENATE ACT COMMITTEE. WE IT'S
NOT MY IT'S NOT WITHIN MY,
PROCEDURE AND RULES TO NEGOTIATE
OFF THE DAIS. AND SO WE DO HAVE
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IN
PRINT. WE ALSO HAVE YOUR
ORIGINAL LANGUAGE, AND SO I
WOULD JUST SUGGEST THAT, WE
EITHER TAKE ONE OF THOSE TWO
ITEMS THAT ARE IN PRINT, UP FOR,
FOR A VOTE. BUT I DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE. AND IT'S NOT SENATE
TO MY UNDERSTANDING. IT'S NOT
SENATE PROCEDURE FOR US TO BE TO
NEGOTIATE LANGUAGE, OFF THE
DAIS. WELL, LET ME SUGGEST THIS,
YOU CAN, PICK WHICH VERSION YOU
WANT TO MOVE, BUT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BRING TO THE FLOOR, AND
WE'LL WORK WITH YOU ON THIS. BUT
WHAT WE WILL BRING TO THE FLOOR
IS A VERSION THAT HAS THE 2029
DATE, WHICH IS DIFFERENT FROM
THE ORIGINAL VERSION THAT DOES
NOT HAVE A MORATORIUM. UNTIL
THEN, THAT ALLOWS THE USE AND
THEN AFTER THAT HAS A MORATORIUM
OR ANOTHER ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
THAT WE, YOU KNOW, NEGOTIATE
WITH YOU. BUT THAT'S AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE THE ASSURANCE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE WILL NOT BE CALLED
BACK. YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN'T GO BACK INTO COMMITTEE. WE
WON'T HAVE TIME THAT THIS IS THE
AGREEMENT. AND THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS TO WHAT THAT
FINAL LANGUAGE LOOKS LIKE THAT
WE BRING TO THE FLOOR. BUT THAT
IS THAT IS OUR INTENTION TO HAVE
EITHER A MORATORIUM AFTER 2029
OR SOME OTHER ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM THAT OUR SPONSORS
AGREE WILL PUT TEETH IN THIS.
BUT BEYOND JUST WHAT'S WHAT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SAYING, NO
MORATORIUM NOW AND NO MORATORIUM
AFTER. SO YOU KNOW THAT THAT
VERSION WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BRING TO THE FLOOR. SO AS LONG
AS THERE'S A COMMITMENT WITH THE
YOUTH THAT WE WORK WITH YOU AND
THAT WE ARE BOTH SATISFIED AS TO
WHAT THAT IS, YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT ON THAT. OKAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY. SO WE'LL
GO PERMISSION TO CONTINUE WITH
COMMENT? YES, PLEASE. YES SO I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY,
SURPRISE, SO I WAS PRESENTING IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND I HEARD
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN HERE, WE
DO NOT NEGOTIATE IN THESE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS. WE VOTE ON
THE LANGUAGE THAT IS PUT IN
FRONT OF US. MY OFFICE WAS NOT
GIVEN ANY OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED HERE TODAY. AND
WE ARE NOT IN ANY POSITION TO
NEGOTIATE ON ANY AMENDMENTS. SO
MY ADHERENCE TO THE CHAIR IS
THAT WE HONOR THE PROCEDURES OF
THE SENATE AND THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE BY OUR STAFF TO AND
OUR CONSULTANTS TO PREPARE US
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. I WOULD
ADVISE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS BILL BY RESUBMITTING IT
NEXT YEAR, BECAUSE AT THIS
POINT, WE ARE READY TO GO TO THE
FLOOR ON THE ADVISEMENT OF THIS
BOARD. THIS COMMITTEE, AND WE
HAVE DONE OUR DUE DILIGENCE TO
LOOK AT WHAT WAS PRESENTED
BEFORE US. AND AS OF TODAY, WHAT
YOU'RE DISCUSSING HERE WAS NOT
PRESENTED BEFORE US. AND WE HAVE
A STRICT RULE TO NOT NEGOTIATE
AT THE DÍAS ANY CHANGES OR ANY
AMENDMENTS. SO WHAT WAS
PRESENTED TO ME IN PRINT? THAT
IS WHAT I'M PREPARED TO VOTE ON.
AND THAT IS WHAT I AM ASKING MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE ON, IS WHAT
IS IN PRINT. THAT IS MY MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PRINT
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND IF I COULD
SPEAK TO THAT. OKAY. JUST JUST A
NOTE FOR THE RECORD, I THINK I
HEARD BOTH THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR INDIRECTLY AND WITH SOME
TREPIDATION, COMMIT TO SOME
DIALOG ABOUT SOME MECHANISM OF
ENFORCEMENT GOING FORWARD. AND I
THINK I HEARD THAT ON THE RECORD
BY BOTH AS WELL AS THE MOTION TO
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, WITH WHAT'S
BEFORE US. THAT'S WHAT I HEARD.
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I
HEARD THAT COME OUT OF BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR. THAT'S
WHAT, IF I MAY, THROUGH THE
CHAIR. THAT'S WHAT I HEARD, TOO.
AND I WE DO HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD, THAT THE
MOTION IS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS. BUT WE ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY UNDER SENATE
INSTRUCTION, THE PRO TEM RULES,
TO RECESS. IF THERE NEEDS TO BE
AN AGREEMENT. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT RECESS HAPPENED, AND I
DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
ANYONE'S MOUTH. MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS IN EFFECT, THAT THE CHAIR
WILL NOT CALL BACK THE BILL IF,
BUT INSTEAD COOPERATE WITH
DISCUSSIONS AROUND, AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM WITHOUT
SPECIFYING WHAT THAT ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM MIGHT BE OR WHAT THAT
LANGUAGE MIGHT LOOK LIKE. THAT'S
WHAT I HEARD DURING THE RECESS.
AND I CHAIR, IF I'M SAYING THAT
PUTTING WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH OR
GOING BEYOND IT'S A GOOD TIME, I
WOULD NEED A MOTION TO CLEAR
THAT UP, ESPECIALLY FOR THE
SENATORS HERE. I WOULD NEED A
MOTION ON THAT. WELL, I OFFER
I'D OFFER A SUBSTITUTE MOTION IF
WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. SO I'M SITTING HERE AS AN
EQUAL PARTICIPANT ON THIS
COMMITTEE WITH NOT A DOCUMENT IN
FRONT OF ME. SO WHATEVER SIDE
CONVERSATIONS WERE HAPPENING IN
RECESS IS WAS NOT PRIVY TO A
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. AND SO I'M
GOING TO OBJECT TO ANY SIDE
CONVERSATIONS OR SIDE DEALS THAT
WERE MADE DURING RECESS BECAUSE
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT PUT IN
FRONT OF THE PUBLIC AND IT'S NOT
PUT IN FRONT OF ME AS A VOTING
MEMBER. I MEAN, WE CAN TAKE A
PIECE OF PAPER AND PUT NO CALL
BACK AND ASK THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR TO SIGN IT. I THINK THAT
SATISFIES SENATE RULES, BUT
THAT'S ALL THAT'S THAT'S THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE USE WITH REGARD
TO THIS KIND OF A MATTER WHERE
THERE'S A PENDING ISSUE THAT IS
NOT GOING TO BE, ASSERTED BY THE
COMMITTEE UNTIL FURTHER DIALOG
HAPPENS. MANAGED BUT NOBODY'S
QUESTIONING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE PART OF THE MOTION. SO WE
DID GET CLARIFICATION THAT ANY
FURTHER AMENDMENTS SHOULD BE
TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS.
CORRECT. THAT'S THE NEXT STEP.
RIGHT. SO WE HAVE THE AMENDMENTS
IN PRINT THAT WE SUGGESTED, AND
WE HAVE A MOTION IS. THAT'S
CORRECT, MADAM CHAIR? OKAY LET'S
DO PASS AS AMENDED. NO
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN THERE.
SO WE PASSED IT AS IT IS. OKAY
SO WE HAVE A MOTION THAT'S
CORRECT MA'AM. ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM TWO AB
1963, A POINT OF ORDER. YES. I
BELIEVE A SUBSTITUTE MOTION WAS
PROFFERED BY SENATOR CORTESE.
OKAY BY ROBERT'S RULES, A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION WOULD HAVE TO
BE HEARD FIRST. OKAY. IF THE
SUBSTITUTE MOTION PASSES, THEN
THE ORIGINAL MOTION DIES. IF THE
SUBSTITUTE MOTION DOESN'T PASS,
THEN THE ORIGINAL MOTION WOULD
BE THE NEXT VOTE TAKEN UP. OKAY,
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE WITH THE
YOUR MOTION. SENATOR DECOURCEY,
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED WITH ANY FURTHER
AMENDMENTS CONSIDERED TO BE
TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
ONGOING COOPERATION WITH THE
ONGOING, SUPERVISION OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT'S THE MOTION.
ONGOING SUPERVISION.
OKAY, SO WHAT DOES SHE WANT US
TO SAY THEN?
OKAY, GO AHEAD AND RECESS ONCE
AGAIN, APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. I
DON'T THINK WE.
TAKE THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE IS BACK TO ORDER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE,
EVERYBODY. WE'RE BACK TO FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 1963.
WE HAD ONE MOTION, THEN WE HAD A
SUBSEQUENT, A MOTION TO WITHDRAW
THE SUBSTITUTE MOTION. OKAY, IT
HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN. WE'RE GOING
BACK TO THE ORIGINAL MOTION
CHAIR, IF I COULD CLARIFY MY
MOTION, YES. MY MOTION IS TO DO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU,
ASSISTANT, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS ON FILE
ITEM TWO. AB 1963. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WITH THE
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
IN APPROPRIATIONS ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE DISCUSSED.
MADAM CHAIR, MAY I SPEAK TO THE
TO THE MOTION BEFORE A VOTE? I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WAS JUST
ARTICULATED IS ESSENTIALLY THE
SAME THING. THE SENATOR WAS
TRYING TO GET IN A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION. I UNDERSTAND
PROCEDURALLY THAT MAY BE
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANTIALLY, BUT
I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT.
THAT'S I THINK, ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WAS JUST ARTICULATED ABOUT THE
PENDING VOTE IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ARGUING FOR,
BASICALLY TRYING TO FIND A WAY
FORWARD TO SOLVE THIS. I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
LEADERSHIP AND PATIENCE, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT OF THE AUTHOR,
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
MOTION. MOTION IS ON FILE ITEM
TWO, AB 1963. FRIEDMAN DO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS HURTADO I, HURTADO I
GROVE. ALVARADO. GIL CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I PADILLA. SENATOR.
PADILLA I SORRY. OKAY. THAT BILL
HAS THREE VOTES AND WE WILL
PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 2436.
THE AUTHOR IS NOT HERE, SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE A RECESS.
YOU'RE HERE FOR ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT. MY WITNESS IS
HERE. WE GOOD TO GO. WELL, THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY
ABOUT AB 2436. THE GOAL OF AB
2436 IS TO KEEP THE BUREAU OF
LIVESTOCK IDENTIFICATION
OPERATIONAL AND REVENUE NEUTRAL
BY ADJUSTING STATUTORY FEES TO
ALIGN WITH THE ACTUAL COST OF
THE VITAL LIVESTOCK INSPECTION
SERVICES. THE BUREAU OF
LIVESTOCK IDENTIFICATION UNDER
CDFA IS FULLY FUNDED BY BRAND
REGISTRATION FEES AND INSPECTION
FEES PAID FOR BY CATTLE
PRODUCERS. RECENTLY, OPERATIONAL
COSTS HAVE SURGED DUE TO
INFLATION, INCREASED WAGES FOR
BRAND INSPECTORS, THE TRANSITION
TO AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE FLEET TO
SUPPORT THE STATE'S CLIMATE
OBJECTIVES, AND OTHER ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES, AB 2436 WILL ENABLE
THE BUREAU TO CONTINUE
PROTECTING CATTLE PRODUCERS FROM
THEFT AND MISAPPROPRIATION OF
LIVESTOCK. WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE
JASON BRYANT WITH THE
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION TO
TESTIFY, GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR, AND SENATORS JASON BRYAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION. WE'RE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL, THE BILL
WOULD ADJUST THE STATUTORY
CATTLE INSPECTION FEES PAYABLE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S BUREAU OF
LIVESTOCK IDENTIFICATION. THERE
ARE 60 HARD WORKING BRAND
INSPECTORS PROVIDING VALUABLE
SERVICES TO BEEF PRODUCERS AND
DAIRY FARMERS IN THE STATE, THE
ROUTINE INSPECTION OF CATTLE,
PREVENT THE LOSS, THEFT OR
STRAYING OR MISAPPROPRIATION OF
LIVESTOCK IN THIS STATE. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
INSPECTION DEPARTMENT IS FUNDED,
THIS BILL HELPS US DO THAT, I
WANT TO MAKE A CLEAR POINT HERE.
THE BILL DOES NOT INCREASE
INSPECTION FEES. IN PRACTICAL
TERMS. IT DOES. AFTER A WHILE,
IT DOES AFTER THE STATUTORY
FEES. IT MERELY CODIFIES THE
EXISTING FEES WHICH HAVE ALREADY
BEEN IN PLACE SINCE JANUARY 1ST,
WHEN THE ADVISORY BOARD, MADE UP
OF PRODUCERS, VOTED TO INCREASE
THEIR FEES FOR THAT SERVICE. THE
BILL ALLOWS THEN THE SECRETARY
TO ADJUST THOSE FEES
ACCORDINGLY. UP OR DOWN
DEPENDING, AND SO THERE'S A Dð A
PROCESS THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE TO
ENGAGE PRODUCERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FEES ARE APPROPRIATE,
THE BILL REFLECTS THAT, AND
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THE AUTHOR TO
BRING IT FORWARD. AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IN THIS ROOM, SEEING
NONE. OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. OKAY. DO
WE HAVE, ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON THIS MEASURE, THE BILL. OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL, AND I'LL SEE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASK FOR RESPECTFUL I VOTE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND CLOSE, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLE A MOTION.
MOTION IS ON FILE ITEM FOR AB
2436 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIZ.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS HURTADO
I, HURTADO I, GROVE. ALVARADO.
GILL I ALVARADO. GILL I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I PADILLA. PADILLA I OKAY
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES AND THAT
BILL IS GOING TO BE PLACED ON
CALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THAT WRAPS UP OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING. WE ARE WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS THAT ARE
ON CALL. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
ASK MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
COME IN AND, FOR A FINAL VOTE.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ASSISTANT. CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM ONE AB 1864 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLONY. A CALL.
CONNOLLY. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS GROVE
ALVARADO. GILL. Ã. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. PLEASE CLOSE THE DOOR
SO THAT WE CAN CONDUCT OUR
MEETING. THANK YOU. FILE ITEM
TWO AB 1963 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GROVE. ALVARADO. GILL SO THAT
ONE'S THREE ZERO ON CALL. THE
MOTION IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS THREE AND
FIVE, AB 2324 AND AB 2721. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE. THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS GROVE,
ALVARADO, GILL. Ã. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE OKAY. WE'LL WAIT FOR
ONE MORE COMMITTEE MEMBER. THANK
YOU.
OKAY, OKAY. WE'RE GONNA. THIS
IS. WE'RE LIFTING THE CALL. THIS
IS THE LAST ONE. AND ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
ONE, AB 1864. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS GROVE
. SO THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT. FILE ITEM TWO AB
1963 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS GROVE,
ALVARADO, GILL. SO THE VOTE IS
THREE ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FOUR AB 2436 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIZ. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO. SENATORS GROVE.
GOES OUT. THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT. THE MOTION IS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEMS THREE AND FIVE, AB 2324
AND AB 2721. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR GROVE, THE VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. ON THAT BILL IS OUT.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY, THAT
WRAPS UP. THANK YOU EVERYONE,
AND WE'LL SEE YOU NEXT TIME.